o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dark
exijo muito bem vindo já é mais um vídeo
e hoje draghi já que dois garis
perguntam vocês que não haja distúrbios
não há no ar conselho sabiam que esta
água da serra da estrela
vocês sabem como funcionam as lendas
certo então pronto este é o segundo
anúncio político surgido em um cilindro
com o olympique fra e você tem que fugir
e apanhar oito páginas é isso jogou já
com chuva já lançou uma auto estrada na
floresta na hora o nosso objetivo
suposta suposta nenhum e encontraram 34
peças achava luchini roschdy zem que uma
motinha polícia a moto bem gostoso ou o
isim suficientes ainda apanhar óbvio
gasolina pra nossa nota só assim é que
nós conseguimos fugir
o canal não tava saindo baixar o volume
ai meu deus o xisto na flash lá não sei
se o único a não ter saída cérebro ontem
que uma peça já não sei o que eu ganhei
não sei mas vai [ __ ] já tava e foge
do meu controle é muito estranho isso
que é contra os punidos pelo para
transmitir a a ajudar a apanhar pelo
timão ligado e chininha sanchez só tem
aqui mas qualquer coisa a fazer é ganhar
as peças junto passar por ela de novo em
nada não saiba é que nenhuma peça é bem
jogado da folha e outra muito bom
tomou mas já mira o copiloto de 2014
caso em que o encontrei primeira já que
uma peça do sul começaram muito bem
ou já com sua música do chinese bicho
meu deus meu meu ego antes do moniz tank
quarteto espera eu tenho que ganhar
quatro peças o km 44 em que evitará que
os chineses
atrás de mim que não sou nem cantar
agora eu não posso entrar ali dentro tem
os mais chatos parece um patch uma truta
otto aviãozinho chinesa já está
transmitindo é um sério né mas o carioca
é meu deus eu não cozinho foi contrária
no burro se eu fingir que sou uma menina
calma ai será que foi atrás de mim não
pode ser que eles também querem comer
meninas kauai meu de obra vamos seguir
só enfrentar a crise aqui e acolá e tudo
em chinês justifica assim a porta à
passagem de uma direito aqui e vamos
sempre dou esquerda você já sabe como eu
sou mas cada um é janaina não não somos
casa encontrei um lugar não tem [ __ ]
nenhuma os seus passinhos de xining
jogador que não é possível encontrarmos
a causa do mal eu canalha porta muito
rápido calma
a luz tem alguém aqui o sushiman anef
soluções locais que ouviu um barulho que
bonito do pedido um novo tubo foi também
lembrou que não só pela profusão cair
agora já são 43 peças acontecer aqui que
me lembro você minuto que uma mulher
foge cara água desapareceu consegui
fugir pessoal não está transmitindo o
vírus e que me deu um pouco aí agora só
faltam três peças para motos e óleo é
óbvio eu vou entrar aqui outra vez
dentro do labirinto que eu acho que em
que mais qualquer coisa tem que ter aqui
mas qualquer coisa
renato tem demônios será que tem bichos
não sei vamos ver muita calma muito para
isso e agora vem chamando ignatz domãnio
e jonas agora sai de casa com o placar a
acontecer nada posso experimentar ali
embaixo será que têm moedas não não tem
nada porque aquilo lá em baixo ou outra
peça que outra pessoa uma roda
porque que os jogos joguinhos de bosta
porque o ilusório de nove jogos do
boston na hora só deixou os pais
quiserem ver mais jogos bons como está
sendo agora em 3d do chinês atrás nem eu
nem sequer investigar nada sobre este
jogo mas eu acho que este jogo tem a ver
com uma história qualquer japonesa e não
saímos tipos algum desses super se o de
um jovem pega e dentro continuando se
vocês souberem de história não deixam
interagir com meu público não deixou se
vocês souberem não é que esta história e
prestígio político se nós estamos
japonês shinichi da criança ela se vocês
souberem história digna y alguns
comentários de obama informar acerca
disso a estatal a eu estava acompanhando
a filha da mãe só não tenha vai ver
crianças o sol montani como uma garota
como tudo isto música que pareça o ceará
enquanto que as da china guarda sabe
vocês foge e se a música das mães cril é
muito confusas trechos muito confusa que
tem uma peça já agora altura o fuso por
futebol lá em cima né se poder ou eu
estou tão sabem um chinês de trás de mim
em não esconder nesta volta da área mas
saem e vão ser comido por nunca vá haver
cem pn e eu não consigo fugir não
consigo pai rodrigo rodrigo do
ronaldinho no seu estádio não estamos
porque vamos arriscar nem percebo que o
disco é uma truta eu não sei nunca leão
marinho banda segue para quem segue de
muito perto e depois vai morrer do sul
estúdio foi
[ __ ] que pariu chuchu
olha já montou já não tocar e agora vou
por 15 euros dos bichos - não fico tem
que fazer ou não sai
ae olha não chega [ __ ] xix e que é
então é isso não vamos ficar por aqui
com espírito espero que vocês tenham
gostado já sabem quanto mais claro
favorito se souberem mais jogos de
terror tipo não como estes jogos bons
mesmo aí nos comentários gays fiquem
bahia até a próxima
o cara do gol